you may already have heard the tree that
owns itself it's had a Wikipedia article
since 2006 there are lots of news
articles about it and a tumblr post that
has as I record this more than 800,000
notes not views notes and there are
already a lot of YouTube videos about
this someone visits this tree in Athens
Georgia and tells a story of how a local
landowner with fond childhood memories
wrote a legal document bestowing the
trees ownership onto itself sometime in
the early 19th century and then they'll
go into a discourse about how under the
actual law there's no legal basis for
that so the ownership is unclear and
then they'll talk about how everyone
just agrees to behave like it is the law
even though this oak tree isn't even
actually the same tree the original one
fell in the 1940s and was replaced and
finally they will talk about how all law
is ultimately based on the social
contract that each is follows what they
don't talk about is the other tree that
owns itself which is about 200 miles
that way in the city of Eufaula just
over the border into Alabama
there is another oak tree with a nearly
identical story it was a city landmark
the local council bestowed the trees
ownership onto itself for everyone just
rolled with it and when the tree
eventually fell in a storm a new one was
put here and everyone just agreed that
it counted as the same tree but this
tree does not have a Wikipedia article
it isn't even referenced on the other
tree's articles at least not as I record
this
there aren't dozens of YouTube videos
about it information about this tree has
been buried under all the search results
and news articles dedicated to the tree
over in Georgia for some reason that one
has better publicity maybe it's because
that one was first by about a century
but given that both of them were deeded
decades before the internet I'm not sure
that's too much of a advantage more
likely it's the same reason that many
different ideas take off while others
don't it's all about who you know the
tree in Georgia is in a big college town
home to the University of Georgia and
home to students who will arrive from
out of town learn the story and then
leave Eufaula here while it's a really
pretty city it has a fraction of the
population and no big reason for
out-of-towners to visit stories don't
tend to spread as well from places like
this hey maybe there are other trees out
there and other some
towns where the same things happened but
I couldn't find any references to them
under the noise made by the one that
everyone noticed if you want a metaphor
for how success on the internet and hack
anywhere works then these trees are it
it's not always about how good your
story is it's about how many people are
willing and able to pass it on
[Laughter]